To get by car here is not possible.
You really have to hike.
This restaurant has been perched in the Swiss Alps for 173 years,...
...and the trek has always attracted hungry hikers.
But it's steep,...
...nearly 5,000 feet up.
Hello, and welcome to the Aescher.
I'm Melanie Gmunder and I'm the manager of the restaurant.
Our food is very traditional.
We got like sausage, cheese, salad or nut croissant.
But before you make any orders, here's how to get there.
First, get to the canton of Appenzell Innerrhoden and head to Wasserauen.
Then cable car it.
You'll go up a distance of over 2,000 feet to the Ebenalp mountain.
Once you get there, have your hiking boots ready for 15 minutes' steep hike,...
...go through a 40,000-year-old cave,...
...pass the chapel and you're there,...
...or you can take a two-hour hike through other paths.